let me ask you the big question of
advice okay
what advice would you give to young
people today
uh that or maybe high school
college thinking about career thinking
about life they can be proud of
so the first thing that i would say is
that life is longer than you think it is
even though i understand the impulse to
be in a rush
you will have many unfoldings
more even than people of my generation
did unfoldings that's just a funny word
that's a beautiful word it's unfolding
it feels that way it's like different
aspects of your life will come
will
will show you different possibilities
that you don't imagine at the moment
and
and i think the second thing that i
would say is
i know that this is a very old-fashioned
but i would say don't
if to the extent that you can read don't
just
and not just on social media read books
learn things that will give you a
broader context for your life than just
today or yesterday
or the day before
and
and
i suppose the other thing that i would
say is
um
that
to the extent that you can
try to develop your own internal metric
of both
what matters and what is good
because you will be exposed to more
voices
than any generation in history telling
you that that's good or this is good
they're called influences influencers
but what they are is voices telling you
what you should think and what you
should believe
and so have some internal space where
you where you'll be able to say for
example i know this person is doing that
and it looks great but that's not me
you have a community of people that
um
speak to you with a lot of passion
and
do you still have that voice in your own
in the privacy of your own mind that uh
you're able to ignore like for a moment
just be with yourself absolutely think
what is right absolutely and i think
it's partly because i grew up without
that i mean
i grew up with a lot of space in my life
and so i had chance to develop that
voice that's why i think it's harder for
kids today than it was for me
i mean i grew up when there were three
channels there was three six and ten
there was abc cbs and nbc and
and that was it and you spent your
evening you know playing board games or
reading or whatever and there was a lot
of space
and we played football in the street and
you went on your bike in the morning and
nobody worried about you and you came
home at night and everybody assumed you
were fine um and and so
i really feel and also i went into
a religious tradition where i feel like
i
i have the opportunity to judge myself
by bigger metrics
um
and it's still hard i don't wanna it's
not like oh it's
i i you know i wear impenetrable armor
it's still hard so
how much harder for kids today when they
don't have that
you mentioned books
is there
bertrand russell and denial of death by
ernest becker is there
books that pop into mind that
like had an impact on you my favorite
novel
is middle march so much middle march i
remember like i was listening to a
podcast i was listening to one of your
podcasts where you said where where your
guests said the two greatest novels of
the 19th century
were uh were brothers karamazov and uh
what was the other one he mentioned i
don't remember
as well or no i think i was both
i might have been i don't remember maybe
but anyway but i would say middle march
is up there middle march like presents
an entire world and it's
written by a woman uh marianne evans who
took the pen name george eliot um
who
you feel
virginia woolf said it's the only
english novel written for grown-ups um
you feel the genius in her sentence it's
like the pressure of her intellect in
her sentences it's a beaut it's a
wonderful wonderful book i love it
pressure of her intellect yeah you
really do um
i also love i love soul bello especially
herzog but but it's a very different
kind of uh
of thinking person's novel i read a lot
of mysteries um and a lot of other kinds
of fiction and literature but
in terms in terms of the books that most
you mentioned one of them which is
viktor frankl's man search for meaning
um
and i also really really love heschel's
the sabbath i think it's a beautiful
book
very sh it's very short book just as
frankl's book is
what do you take from the masters for
meaning what what do you take of a human
being in in the worst conditions being
able
to um
non-dramatically yeah find little joys
find
find beauty
and it's it's what i said before about
judaism's advice to younger people is
that it matters if you believe that
something matters you have enormous
resilience it's meaninglessness that is
the greatest threat to a decent life
when people are like deeply depressed
whether it is chemical depression or
what they feel like is this is all
meaningless
yeah and
and meaning now obviously
chemical depression calls in part for
chemical means
but but meaning is the it's the great
antidote um
we can talk about what kind of meaning i
mean there are kinds of meanings that
are awful but
but meaning is the great antidote to
a sense that life is just nihilistic and
purposeless and
and to that destructiveness that i think
is
too common
yeah so maybe maybe the heroic action
in nazi germany in the holocaust in the
camps is the even not the action but
just the realization that every life
matters so here's this really wonderful
story that hugo grin who was a
who was a rabbi in england i don't know
like 15 20 years ago he used to tell he
grew up in auschwitz
he was a child there and he was with his
father and it was hanukkah and you're
supposed to light the candles and his
father took the margarine ration and
used it as the oil to light the hanukkah
candles and hugo said was scandalized
and he said that's our food and his
father said what we have learned my son
is you can live for three weeks
without food you can live for three days
without water but you can't live for
three minutes without hope
you